it was absolute genius marketing so if
you guys didn't know as of last night
the Barbie movie surpassed a billion
dollars in Revenue
that is unheard of for a movie with this
kind of budget I mean you're talking
about Avengers
uh infinity War level stuff and you're
talking about an ensemble cast of some
of the biggest stars and actors in
Hollywood that are hitting that one
billion
so
this is on crazy numbers if you have if
you live under a rock and you're not on
social media at all or if you haven't
just opened your door and listen to
people talk everybody's talking about
the Barbie movie everybody's getting
dressed up to go to the theater people
are wearing pink you have grown women
wearing pink you have grown men wearing
pink to go to the movie theater
and
I was watching the trailer actually
earlier today because essentially what
they did is they
in a nutshell they took a brand as
recognizable as Barbie that women in
their 30s and 40s and 50s and 60s at
this point
um will remember playing with Barbies
growing up and so this was sort of the
perfect bait for older women or uh that
had grown up with Barbie and also that
may have daughters if they wanted to
sort of impart this sort of oh this is
amazing part of my childhood sort of
thing onto their daughters or young
women in their life
and millions of people have seen this
thing and so the reason I call it genius
is because
they didn't give anything away as far as
what the movie overall was going to be
about I mean they played really fast and
loose with the actual plot
and what they actually gave for two
hours you know I was watching the
trailer and I thought oh this is going
to be uh this is selling a quirky movie
about a doll who gains sentience and
then goes into the real world and gets
into all kind of wacky and funny mishaps
and Adventures like a light-hearted
family kind of movie
and essentially what it really was is a
two hour long feminist propaganda atomic
bomb
so I definitely want to chat a little
bit more about you know what brought me
to those conclusion uh so much of the
movie
that I had issue with I mean I was
trying to really rack my brain as I was
thinking about what I was going to talk
about on this cast to find
any sort of redeemable moment whatsoever
during the movie I just couldn't find
one I thought there were opportunities
there were certainly opportunities where
they had a chance to
say hey this is all satire or
I'll get into the movie they had plenty
of chances to bring that home and and
try to make it seem like it wasn't so
heavy-handed but I mean it was a it was
a pure disaster so the movie opens in
Barbie land you got Margot Robbie as the
stereotypical Barbie and they've got a
whole bunch of different Barbie
characters they had pregnant Barbie
which you find out
um was an actual Barbie but was
discontinued so first shot at motherhood
there uh basically the whole day is a
party Barbie drives her fictional car to
the fictional Beach
you have all of the Barbies and I'm
gonna start I don't know how many times
I'm gonna have to say Barbie throughout
this cast and Barbie and Ken I'm
probably just going to start saying men
and women if I can help it
but the Barbies are all
center of attention and they're all
happy-go-lucky and they're saying hi to
each other and they're just couldn't
have a care in the world every day is
the best day ever and the Ken's are just
on the beach
and they're dancing and they're
strutting and they're posing and they're
all six pack abs and stuff like that
like a Ken doll would and all they're
doing is trying to get the attention of
the Barbie's character specifically Ryan
Gosling's character is trying to get the
attention of Margaret Robert's Barbie
character they even go so far as to say
the Ken his job is Beach it's not
lifeguard it's not Beach Patrol it's not
anything it's Beach just the word Beach
so right off the bat we're seeing that
men have been reduced to absolutely have
no value whatsoever and they are
their only purpose in life is to be
noticed by Barbie
so this continues Barbie throws a big
soiree at her Barbie dream house that
night and then she starts to have
intrusive thoughts she see the music all
stops she says something to the line the
effect of you guys ever think about
dying and obviously that's sort of a
taboo thought in Barbie land in not to
bore you guys with all the details but
what happens is
there's some Rift in the time space
continuum between the Barbie world and
the real world the Barbie and the Barbie
world starts becoming more humanoid she
gets a flat feet for example and then
she starts getting cellulite and then
she has these intrusive thoughts and so
it's revealed that she has to go to the
real world and find this child that is
playing with her
get her to think happy thoughts again or
repair her relationship with Barbie
still kind of fuzzy to me I try not to
focus on the really woo-woo stuff
and then Ken Ryan Gosling's character so
so Barbie goes to on her road trip and
she's going to go to the real world and
Ken stows away in her back seat right
always wanting her approval Ken gets Ken
rides in the back seat Barbie rides in
the front he doesn't even ride shotgun
in this movie
so they get to La they get to Venice
Beach everybody's kind of seen the
leaked photos of roller skates and
things like that so they're going roller
skating and right off the bat you're hit
with this
laziest most stereotypical screen or
anything you can ever get there's a
scene where they're when they're
rollerblading and there's a group of
college kids that are like pooping and
hollering at Robbie's Barbie they've run
into a construction site where there's
four fat construction dudes that are
saying lines you haven't heard since you
were five like do you want have some
fries with that shake and stuff like
that and so it's just it's right off the
bat it's so
it's so heavy-handed that you think it
might be satire and it's not it's not
satire this is this is truly the way
that Greta gerwick thinks and the
director rig and I knew this was going
to be a garbage movie when I when I
learned that she was the director she
had directed
um
Little Women and then Lady Bird I think
which two like very coming of age for
women movies and she's been on the up
and up as far as directors go
and so so what do they do what are they
here to do so Barbie is here to
find this little girl and change your
opinion of Barbie so all is right in the
world so she splits up but at the same
time we're taken to the Mattel offices
where the Mattel is a company that owns
Barbie
and just like in stereotypical fashion
the entire boardroom is made up of
bumbling stumbling idiot men Led Led by
no other than
king of playing bumbling stumbling
idiots Will Ferrell and a bunch of guys
who never learn their names and of
course the one woman in the office is
the secretary that's the only job uh in
this universe that apparently she is
she's good enough
so these guys get word that
Barbie's out and they said oh this could
cause a huge problem and we can't let
this get out this is going to be a huge
issue and so they go out to find her
they go out to try to catch her and so
at the same time Ken is off experiencing
a world for the first time where people
are looking at him differently because
he's a man they're treating him well
they're saying what's up to him they're
recognizing him they're giving him
they're saying he has value
and then he starts to get this pompous
attitude and this sort of unearned
confidence where now he starts marching
into
doctor's offices and saying I want to be
a doctor or a Banker's office and saying
I want to be a banker and I need to have
this because
I'm a man so this whole thing about this
unearned unearned confidence because
this guy marches into this office and
just says well I'm a man so I deserve
this and I earn this not that I heard it
I just get it I should you should give
it to me because I'm a man so again the
stereo the stereotypes are in full swing
here I mean it's absolutely unbelievable
and it's I haven't I don't know a single
man
that acts like that
the men that I know and the circles that
I run in guys understand they have to
put in the work and they have to do work
now I'm not saying there aren't guys out
there I think there are plenty of guys
out there that think they are somehow
entitled whether that's to female
attention or whether that's to jobs or
positions or nice things
but it's very
it's very rarely I don't ever hear it
saying well because I'm a man I deserve
this it's more so I'm a nice guy or I'm
a good person or I'm all these other
this and that
so I deserve this
and so
Ryan Gosling's can he goes back to
Barbie world he says oh I've seen I've
seen what the real world is like where
men dominating everything and he has
this weird obsession with horses I guess
it's supposed to be funny it's really
not
um so he goes back to Barbie land Barbie
finds this
her Girl owner I guess
and there's this really weird
interaction in the lunchroom where like
a 14 year old girl says Barbie setback
feminism 50 years and calls Barbie a
fascist and it's like no 14 year old
talks like that
no 14 year old girl
has any any sort of
excuse me like they don't they don't
know what that means it's like clearly
this is you know that the director
putting this stuff into a 14 year old
girl's character it's just
it was really bad
I don't know what else to say
um Barbie gets captured by the Mattel
guys
and again a very over-the-top
heavy-handed they get out a toy box or
they get out a Barbie plastic box and
they say Barbara you get back in the box
they're trying to put women back in a
box like just lazy hand-handed
screenwriting so Barbie outsmarts all
the Mattel Executives who are all men
and here's something I want to call out
too
um and this will kind of resurface it a
little bit but
Mattel's board of directors made up of
11 people
five of them are women
so
almost half and you can't have half of
11. but they're not even going for
accuracy they're going for the most
ham-handed stereotype that you could
possibly get in this in this situation
so Barbie escapes she finds her way back
to Barbie land and she comes back to
find Barbie land completely different
than what she once left it Ken has
turned all of the Ken's into the leaders
now and all of the Barbies are no longer
the CEOs and the Supreme Court Justices
and the lawyers and the doctors and the
business owners and all of these things
that Barbie and feminism is telling
women that they can be
and they've essentially turned into
I don't want to say house Barbies but
like house Barbies Housewives and
they're taking care of some of the kids
and
Barbie decides that these other Barbies
and these women Margot Robbie decides
that all of these other
Barbies are brainwashed so now it's her
job to team up with the other
sort of outcast Barbie
played by Kate McKinnon to essentially
kidnap all of the other Barbies and
unbrainwash them
and it really struck a chord with me and
it really
it's what feminism gets so wrong I think
about women and women having equal
rights and all that kind of stuff
they're just taking Choice completely
out of it there's there's nothing in
there that says like this is where the
movie had such a missed opportunity
and this is kind of at the end I'm kind
of going to the end and coming back but
there was such an opportunity to say
listen some of the Barbies let's say we
on brainwash to Barbies
but they still chose to be a Barbie wife
or a house Barbie or a Barbie mother
and we would say that's okay
it's all about the important the
importance is about choice and about
what you're what you can do with the
knowledge that you've gained but this
whole idea of a Barbie taking care of a
Ken or being with a Ken is not a choice
it's brainwashing so you're you're
essentially telling women that the only
reason they would ever be side by side
with a man and be taking care of him or
adding value to his life as if she's
brainwashed and we need to get her away
from Ken and we need to re-brainwash her
or unbrainwasher
so now she wants to be the doctor the
Supreme Court Justice or a lawyer or
anything all this good stuff
and there's one particular scene that
really like stuck out more than most
um
and so there's this the whole idea of
they're trying to pull one over on these
cans to get power back because the Ken's
have revolted and now they're going to
write a new constitution to say Ken's
have all the power now and Barbies don't
have the power anymore and so what they
do is they
pretend to be interested in these cans
they pretend to be infatuated with them
and it culminates in this one big scene
where all of the Ken's are playing
guitar to a Barbie on the beach
and all of them are doing it and so it's
funny like again very over the top the
song they pick is Push by Matchbox 20.
I'm not going to read the lyrics or I'm
not going to talk about it with you guys
um
but
it kind of culminates in this final sort
of campfire scene where
they pretend to be interested in right
when they even and they say this
explicitly they say like we're gonna
pretend to be interested and then right
at the right moment when we think we
have them hooked they'll pull out their
phones
act uninterested and disinterested and
the guy goes Hey listen
um you know because who are you texting
he's like oh just another kitten and
this winds
this winds up hitting all of the men
together and the men actually go to war
on a beach like a beach battle while all
the Barbies conspire behind their backs
to redo the Constitution or celebrate
how stupid men are and how idiotic they
are
I want to go back really quick because
this is probably the most important part
of the entire film that I disagree with
well let me let me wrap it up and we'll
come back to this because I'm almost to
the end I kind of skipped over but I
kind of skipped over on purpose
so
eventually what happens is
the kids realize they've been played for
fools
and all along
Ryan Gosling's entire motivation of
changing Barbie world to Ken world and
taking over is because he's essentially
friend zoned by Barbie and even at the
very end of the movie he has a breakdown
and she coddles him and hugs him and
stuff and he goes in to kiss her and
they let you know very clear that it's
not going to happen that the girl and
the guy are not going to end up together
this is not some stupid sappy rom-com
from the 80s sorry to burst your bubble
and it ends with this weird Soliloquy
about how
I'm Barbie it's not Barbie and Ken it's
Barbie
and then there's Ken
and essentially the whole movie says it
it is closing and wrapping up
trying to tell
women that they're better off without
men and men you don't you don't need
women dude like you're just you're
enough you're Ken enough
k-e-n-o-u-g-h he literally wears a
sweatshirt at the end of the movie that
says Kenneth and I think there's memes
going around I think Trudeau probably
put one on or something like that
like that um
but
it's just it overall it's just such a
horrible horrible message in my opinion
opinion and I don't believe that it's
satire I know that wahlburger said it
sat there it's not satire
like
if it was satire it would be I think
obvious I mean you
you take a director like Gary and you
see the stuff that she's putting out
it's really not satire trying to send a
message this is really the reality that
women think they live in they think they
live in this reality where they have to
be in constant fear of men where every
three seconds you've got
fat construction workers that are
oogling and ogling and ooping and
hollering at them they think they live
in a world where every board of
directors is run by men and the only
jobs that women are allowed for are
secretariately
it's just a complete misrepresentation
of the reality of the world that we
actually live in
and so they all drive off into the
sunset Barbie ends up going to the real
world I guess because she fixed Barbie
land and now it's up to her to fix the
real world I don't really know what the
the end I was so out of it by the the
last you know 10 minutes I was I was
kind of over it and done with it
but there was one point and this I got
wind of this before I even saw the movie
because there's a
there's a very
specific moment where
the Mother character from The Real World
who is really the culprit of playing
with the dolls the wrong way that broke
the space time don't try to follow along
with that you're gonna I'm gonna hurt
myself even trying to think
but she opens it so so Margot Robbie has
this moment where she looks around and
nobody wants her and nobody is taking
her seriously all the other Barbies have
all the other cans and the Ken and this
is it's so it's so poetic and this isn't
what they meant but
this is really how things happen so she
went from having all of this attention
and everybody was obsessed with her
because she was young and hot Barbie she
was stereotypically hot Barbie she was
the Barbie of the Barbies now nobody
wants anything to do with her nobody
wants to talk to her nobody wants any of
this kind of stuff even Ryan Gosling who
was obsessed with her who has now said
whatever I'm done with you I'm over it
she has this major breakdown and she
says I'm not good at anything I'm not a
doctor I can't fly planes I'm not
interesting I'm not smart I'm not
beautiful
and she essentially is hitting the wall
in real time and the guys that watch
this content know what I'm talking about
she's hitting the wall in real time
she's recognizing that the power she
used to have
the attention she used to command
she's no longer getting it it's over and
so
that is her motivation
to go in unbrainwash these other Barbies
nobody wants her she's past her prime
she's hit the wall she's gotten zeroed
out so what does she do she wants to go
and make sure all of those other Barbies
are just as miserable as she is misery
loves company in this particular
and when the Barbies were actually
taking care of the Kens they were happy
they were ecstatic there was one that
even made the comment where she goes
this is so much better than being
president
and it's like
yeah
exactly they tried to make that satire
but I
I was talking to some I was I was
talking to my LTR about this last night
and I said look like if you take 99 of
the bossiest boss babes ever
with the wall of fancy degrees framed in
Mahogany there's all the money in the
bank and the VP and the CFO CEO titles
and all this stuff
20 years of climbing the corporate
ladder and having to play the game
I guarantee that 99 of women out there
if they ran into a guy that was like you
don't have to do that anymore
I got this I'm going to take care of it
you never have to worry about paying
another bill you never have to worry
about buying another this you never have
to worry about any of this other stuff
I'm gonna take care of I'm gonna handle
it 99 of women would take that deal
and the speech that this when we get I'm
gonna actually read you guys the speech
now
if this gets copyrighted in any sort of
strike maybe I won't read the whole
thing I want to try to be very careful
with like copyright infringement I know
I can't show any clips
this stuff is like
is widely shared like lines from the
movie so I don't think it's that big a
deal so I am going to read it and this
is this is really what first set me off
on this movie and this is what I kind of
wanted to delve into the most
um and where I think overall we're going
so let me read it really quick so this
what has happened yeah Moe this is
you're exactly right so this is the
woman having so hard speech
um now there's going to be some things
that I agree with this I'm not going to
call this moment in time completely
trash and I'll tell you guys why here in
a minute
but this is essentially what she says
Barbie has just had her breakdown she
says I'm not good at anything I can't do
anything I can't fly a boat or fly a
ship or I can't drive a boat or I'm not
smart all this kind of stuff so this is
this is the quote in its entirety she
goes it is literally impossible to be a
woman you are so beautiful talking to
Barbie you are so beautiful and smart
and it kills me that you don't think
you're good enough like
we have to always be extraordinary but
somehow we're always doing it wrong you
have to be thin but not too thin you can
never say you want to be thin you have
to say you want to be healthy but you
also have to be thin you have to have
money but you can't ask for money
because that's crass you have to be a
boss but you can't be mean you have to
lead but you can't squash other people's
ideas you're supposed to love being a
mother but don't talk about your kids
all the time you have to be a career
woman but also always be looking out for
other people you have to answer for
men's bad behavior which is insane but
if you point that out you're accused of
complaining
you're supposed to stay pretty for men
but not so pretty that you tempt them
too much or that you threaten other
women because you're supposed to be a
part of The Sisterhood but always stand
out and always be grateful but never
forget that the system is Rich so find a
way to acknowledge that but also always
be grateful you never have to get old
sorry you have to never get old never be
rude never show off never be selfish
never fall down never fail never show
Fear never get out of line it's too hard
exclamation point it's too contradictory
and nobody gives you a medal or says
thank you and it turns out in fact that
not only are you doing everything wrong
but also everything is your fault
I'm just so tired of watching myself in
every single other woman I herself into
knots so that people will like us and if
all of that is also true for a doll just
just representing women then I don't
even know
that I heard this and I or I've read it
for the first time
and it just it
it blew my mind man like honestly
because this is this is something that
I've had a lot of conversations with a
lot of conversations about recently
and
I don't disagree
that there are women out there that felt
like that feel like they are held to
Impossible standards
but what this movie fails to do is point
the gun point the barrel of the gun at
the right people and it's not the men
this entire movie is predicated on the
fact that men are the enemy towards
women and men only want to keep women
down and men have these unbelievable
standards for for women which they must
achieve and they must do otherwise
they're not going to be good enough
and this goes out to all the women out
there that believe that I'm sorry that
you've been lied to for so long
I'm sorry that you've
this comment
dude don't come in the comment section
and say stupid like women are the
enemy like
I'm gonna ban you so fast dude
um don't do that stuff
because it's exactly not what we're
trying to achieve here
and so this idea of
it's all men's standards and it's all
men holding us to this and men telling
us we need to be this it's just not true
you know the people that are saying this
it's the people that are pushing the
magazines that you read like
Cosmopolitan it's the mainstream media
that are selling you makeup and fitness
and beauty products that are telling you
that if you don't wear this if you don't
put on our makeup if you don't buy our
clothing you're going to be single no
man is going to want you and they're
preying on the female hypergamous nature
and the
competition anxiety that women feel when
it comes to competing with other women
for men
and people might even say like oh well
the corporations are you know all run by
men so deep down it is still men and I
have two issues with that statement one
even if that were true it's not spoiler
alert it's not even if that were true
you're talking about a very very small
subset of hyper just to steal and rip
off from
um Jordan Peterson
um
it's a small modicum of hyper successful
men that are making these small
decisions and they're making these
they're they're putting these things
emotions people in power
it's not the everyday guy that you meet
on the street or meet on a dating app or
a guy that actually wants to find a good
woman and be with her
and so what this is doing it's painting
men as the enemy and it's driving men
and women further apart and I've said
this from the from the minute I've heard
this I've always supported it I truly
believe that men and women are better
together than they are apart we're
complementary towards one another
so men and women are better together
than they are apart and this comes this
goes for all things this goes for child
rearing this goes for the you know
advancement of our our race and our
species and our human race
and all this movie did was talk about
how men and women don't need each other
and they're actually better apart
you're Ken enough Hey guys you're Ken
enough
and it's these people that run these
companies and these magazines that are
telling you that you're gross and that
you're you're too fat when you need to
be a boss babe you need to go make all
this money this is the result and here
comes the big reveal guys like this is
what feminism has done
to us this is the result
of feminism this is the result of a
system
and a narrative that tells women that
you're both better than men but you're
also oppressed by them at the same time
this is a narrative
that has said
go make all the money if you're a woman
go get all the degrees spend 20 years
climbing the corporate ladder
and then when you're done there's going
to be loads and swaths of men that are
going to be falling at your feet because
they're just going to be so sexually
attracted to your wall of degrees and
all of the zeros in your bank account
and it's just not the reality
again the movie had a perfect
opportunity to say
if you want to
go and work and be boss babe Barbie
forever and be Supreme Court Justice
Barbie or be president Barbie
cool you can do that
if you want to be stay-at-home Barbie
and raise the children Barbie and take
care of the home Barbie and clean the
house and cook for your family and make
sure they grow up healthy and strong
Barbie and make sure your kids aren't
maladjusted for the world Barbie you can
do that as well
but we have to end this lie we have to
end this lie that the world is telling
women that you can have it all
it's just not the way that it works
you have to be able to make a choice
like I'm sorry like nobody can have it
I'm not just talking to women here I'm
talking to everybody nobody can just
have it all and more importantly
women are the most disaffected when it
comes from the people that are preaching
this feminist nonsense saying that you
can do whatever you want and Men Are
Gonna it's just
you can do whatever you want but
understand the choices on the table for
you and what consequences are going to
stem from those choices
and it's because
we'll
there's a lot of lack of holding people
accountable these days and I'm not going
to turn this into we need to hold women
accountable I'm not going to do that
kind of stuff
but the people I want to hold
accountable are the people that are
telling them this stuff only to profit
for them the this is all here's the
thing I I I don't see how people don't
get this
and if you still believe that the people
in power in the government and the
people at the top of you know your
favorite corporations corporate ladder
and exec board
if you still think they have your best
interest in mind if they care about you
I mean I don't know how else to show you
that
do you have an IQ below from 70.
explain it to me how
years ago or whenever this sort of third
wave of feminism started I don't know
70s or 80s essentially like the sexual
revolution in the in the pill came out
that these men because let's face it
I agree that many years ago enough years
ago women weren't allowed to do things
like old credit cards they weren't
allowed to buy houses without a husband
signing off they weren't allowed to do a
lot of things without a man president or
like a husband or a brother or something
present and I get all that I'm not
saying that's right I'm saying that's
the reality of how things work
but the point is that
for women to be able to get to a place
where they are now where they've enjoyed
all these equal rights and equal
freedoms and they're actually outpacing
men in a lot of areas college education
I mean they're they're actually starting
to make more money than men in the
corporate workplace
um more representation than ever before
in government and positions of power but
there's
logically
do you really think that these men sat
around in their leatherback chairs and
cigars and said hey you know what
I'm kind of tired of being in power I'm
kind of tired of having all of these
opportunities I'm kind of tired of
you know being the Apex and and uh being
the ruler of everything and only being
able to have rights or certain rights
that I can have that women have and
we're just kind of tired of it we're
tired of all these amazing things that
we get to enjoy let's let's just bring
women on for a change what the hell
let's just throw them a bone you know
let's let's give them you know ammo and
give them a bunch of money ammo isn't
like ammo to fight us give them a bunch
of money and you know give them a bunch
of degrees so they can be on equal
footing so they can now come into
government and they can come into all
our eyes wide shut parties and our
closed off meetings that's not what
happened
because it would men had to step aside
men had to pave the way for feminism
it's just the way that it was men had to
pave that way
and these people empowering these people
in these positions did not do it
because of that
they thought hmm how do we benefit from
this there's a huge Uprising where all
these women are saying we want to be
able to have credit cards we weren't
able to do this we want to be able to do
that well how do we profit on this as
much as humanly possible
well let's take a look how does the
government make its money taxes
how do you get more taxes more people
have to make more money
so you had one half of the population
men the only half of the population that
was actually working
so that was the only half of the
population that you could tax
you'd only tax men
couldn't tax women because they didn't
have an income
so what do you do you drive men and
women apart you tell women that they no
longer need men because they're strong
and independent
you raise entire generations of women
saying men are the enemy and you better
be able to stand on your two feet
because men one day will leave you so
make as much money as you possibly can
and get as educated as you can because
men will just ditch you and not take
care of you and they will leave you in
the dust at the minute at a hatch notice
and drop off minutes notice I got those
backwards
and all that does
line the pockets of the people in
positions of power all it does is lie in
the pockets of the people that are
pushing beauty products and pushing
Fitness Products on women because of
this all it's doing is lining the people
that are pocketing your taxpayer dollars
it behooves these people to keep men and
women apart as much as humanly possible
when people are together and when people
are bonded together if you guys didn't
catch what I said last week about
importance of Brotherhood and groups and
tribes when people are together and
they're they're harder to govern people
are banded together they're harder to
tell what to do they're harder to bring
but individuals are very easy
to govern
and so
we have to talk about this everybody
thinks yeah there you go everybody
thinks it's like some wild conspiracy
man like if you know anything about the
Rothschilds you know anything about the
Rockefellers like Moe's on it tonight
man like do your basic research on this
stuff there's a reason the Rockefellers
and the Rothschilds have been in power
have been at the the center of the money
making Universe for
decades I mean 100 100 years at this
point or more
or more so you guys got to wake up man
and this is the thing
this Barbie movie under the guise of
Barbie and flashy lights and pink and
Nostalgia they've essentially dropped
the feminism atom bomb
and there's gonna be people out there
that are going to say stuff like oh but
Mom like it's just a movie well tell the
lady that went viral on Twitter when she
tweeted I'm sitting in Oppenheimer saw
that too by the way gratefully you
should check it out
she goes I'm sitting through Oppenheimer
and it's 23 minutes in before a woman
speaks
so if you're going to take that stance
and that's not just a movie even though
it's a period piece and it's accurate to
the times and the type of people that
we're working on the atom bomb back in
the 40s
I mean read a history book dude
you don't get to say it's just a movie
when you talk about millions of people
that have gone to see this you don't get
to talk about it's just a movie when
it's made a billion dollars in Revenue
because there's going to be people that
are gonna there's the young girls that
are going to see this movie that are
saying like wow the Kens are all kind of
pieces of huh
and I could be all this stuff and I
don't need Ken
and it's my job as Barbie as the new and
improved Barbie to go out into the real
world and fix things and change things
and make it so men aren't these just
creatures and these Colossus of the
cloud and these guys that are just the
world just Falls at their feet
I was going to get into a little bit
tonight about you know some of the stuff
that Dr Warren Farrell talks about in
his book The Myth of male power I think
that's you know time for for another
night
um and I've ripped about as long as I
possibly can on this but I definitely
want to open it up to to some callers
let me get to join link and stuff like
that ready
um I'm gonna put the comment
in the chat here so guys can start
coming in
um if you saw the movie let me know I
mean and look I think the movie was
perfectly summed up by the very last
scene Barbie gets taken to this like a
job interview it actually turns out to
be a gynecologist appointment haha
hilarious but
the husband of this woman area America
ferrara's character who delivers a
speech and the the husband of this woman
and the father of her young daughter
makes only his second appearance on
screen the first time it was a quick
little quip about oh should we tell Dad
no he's probably busy and he's like
sitting on the couch
like reading a Spanish book so they two
seconds of screen time there and they
make him look stupid and then
he's in the passenger seat of the car
that America Ferrera is driving
and then he turns around and he starts
speaking Spanish to Barbie and like
broken Spanish and then his daughter and
I literally went like this I made some
gesture I can't remember what it was and
his daughter goes dad that's
appropriation
it's an absolute clown rule man like if
you guys saw the movie I'm interested to
hear your thoughts
um if you haven't and you just want to
Riff on something then then go right for
it I have somebody that says you might
want to call in so I'm going to send her
the link
is the join link
while I'm doing that
so get in here man to join links right
here I'm going to paste it again if you
guys want to ask questions you want to
do some q a kind of stuff like I said
it's right there I've got my assistant
that's uh kind of
um
spamming the
the calling Link in the chat let's look
at the Super Chat real quick Jerry Oak
25 you're hitting a home run off yeah
thank you man Jerry's a good guy man
like so Jerry and I have been going way
back like I used to do these shows I
don't do much anymore but I used to do
them on this little app called stereo
which is like an all audio
app and you don't show your face and I
probably don't like
I don't know man probably like close to
500 shows on this thing so I um
got a lot of practice and so rich and I
have gone back and forth on that app you
know before and you felt confident and
give me the keys to the king I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out